ich muss mal kurz sauber machen weil
hast du es dreckig gemacht ich hab
dreckig gemacht schon zu oft
angefch so pass auf so jetzt ist es
Moment ich mach noch mal so
sauber son sieht's nicht gut aus ne es
sieht immer noch nicht richtig gut aus
in die Spülmaschine heute Abend das ist
das Fragenlotto ja ich kenne das
Fragenlotto nein ich hoffe du bist ein
Fan ich bin ein großer Fan und ich werde
auch mit einer roten Frage anfangen ist
eigentlich eher so ein alt rosa und das
möchten wir nicht thematisiert werden
wir haben das als rot definiert du TST
das selbst zusammen das ist pass auf wir
tackern das selbst zusammen ich möchte
mal möchte hier paar Details erklären
vielleicht kannst du es zeigen wir
tackern das selbst an jeder Seite
zusammen dann schneiden wir es hier oben
und unten ein so dass nur noch ein
dünner Steg steht dann drücken wir noch
mit einer Zange die Klammern zusammen
damit man sich die Fingernägel nicht
Verl W ist denn wir überhaupt je nachdem
gerade Zeit hat jetzt gerade hat der
Fabian gemacht aber ma ich genauso Fabi
danke schön soste Frage rote Frage
wann kommen die
Außenseiter Quatsch wie lebt sich so als
Pechvogel ich bin ein Pechvogel weil du
bist ein Pechvogel weil weil das
natürlich alles autobiograisch und das
alles ähnlich erlebt hast
ja ich empfinde selten Dinge als Pech
ich habe vor wenigen Tagen hat jemand
mein mein Online Banking angegriffen hat
mir Geld ja hat mir Geld gestohlenöllig
abgefahren richtig total gruselig
unheimlich ich habe auch keine Ahnung
wie es gemacht hat die Polizei hat noch
nicht wirklich Ahnung wie es gemacht hat
also trotz PIN und Tanz gerade der hat
eine TAN abgefangen und hat mit dieser
tan dann seine eigene beweisung gemacht
während ich überwies hat er halt aus
meinerüberweisung seine eigene gemachtin
und da habe ich ganz da könnte man jetzt
ja denken so oh nein und so ein Pech
und aber
erstens mich bringt das dann immer so
eine Position ich möchte nicht sagen
Demut oder aber das dann wieder so zu
schätzen weiß wie wie lange das gut
gegangen ist mit dem Online Banking weil
ich mE seit 10 Jahren ist nie was
passiert dann habe ich gedacht kannst du
eine Geschichte raus machen kannst was
lustiges draus machen und dann habe ich
auch noch Glück gehabt weil die Bank
halt gesagt hat ist ganz klar unsere
Verantwortung sie bekommen das von uns
zurück also ich würde nicht sagen ich
bin Pechvogel weil ich ganz oft aus
Situation wo andere vielleicht sagen
würden es ist Pech was positives
rausziehen was ziehst du da positives
raus die Erfahrung ich habe es überlebt
und es hätte viel schlimmer kommen
können weißt du was ich mal draus ziehe
super Geschichte um habe ich ganz
ähnlich ja absolut schmeiß das da rein
oder daneben oder wo du möchtest rote
noch eine rote wie lebt sich so als
Pechvogel ja jetzt wissen wir immer was
positives
drausziehen findest du deine Cartoons
immer witzig ja ja also ich bin mir ganz
sicher dass viele wie hät es eigentlich
g solche in die Kamera od ne mich
eigentlich aber egal ich habe das B ich
habe jetztst mal so akzeptiert alles
klar es ist so ich würde ein Cartoon
nicht eine Idee nicht zeichnen wenn ich
nicht denken würde sie ist witzig
und hinterher stell ich schon manchmal
auch fest so mit dem Abstand von ein zwe
Jahren wenn ich mir den angucke warum
habe ich das gemacht und was wollte ich
daich erzählen aber das weiß
ich in dem Augenblick und
dann weil dann gibt's genügend Leute die
das auch diesen Augenblick erkennen oder
volollkom richtig aber Humor ist ja
immer subjektiv und man verändert sich
auch und es kann gut sein dass ich mir
Sachen heute angucke mit Abstand und
denke es ist überhaupt nicht witzig aber
von daher wenn ich ihn mache finde ich
ihn immer witzig gut es ist gibt ja auch
immer diese Grenze zum ganz flachen GCK
der aber auch trotzdem ein Brüller sein
kann und man weiß es nie ist das jetzt
total flach was ich mache oder ist es
sophisti ganz oft wenn wenn ich irgendwo
auftrete oder so so eine Signierstunde
auf der Buchmesse habe werde ich auf
Cartoons angesprochen wo ich denke boah
es ist echt nur so ein
Klauer so ein Klassiker ist links im
Bild steht so ein älterer Herr mit
Koffer in der Tür rechts im Bild steht
halt so ein Phantom mit einer Maske und
der der ältere Herr sagt Phantom und das
Phantom sagt der Opa und den wollte ich
erst gar nicht machen und ich werde
immer wieder draf angesprochen oder kam
Nacht auch wird man eigentlich mal von
Kollegen auch angefeindet so nach dem
was machst du für flache GS auf jeden
Fall Sport zwischen uns da s boah das
hast du dich getraut und das ist so
billig oder was natürlich auch mal geht
s so Frauen Männer thememen und Frauen
mit Schuhen und das ist eigentlich
unterste Schublade das ist gibt Komiker
die Leben davon habe ich gehört sage ich
nicht so aber wir haben jedenfalls
eigentlich den Anspruch natürlich so aus
dieser Mischung Bild und Text möglichst
anspruchsvoll toll umgesetzt und da kann
man aber auch völlig daneben liegen gut
alles klar ich ma jetzt noch eine grüne
und dann ma ich die letzte R wo hast du
sens so sensationell zeichnen gelernt oh
kann ich sensationell zeichnen
ich glaube nicht dass ich so
sensationell zeichnen kann aber das ist
sehr zweckmäßig wie ich zeichne lass
mich ein Stillleben zeichnen oder oder
was was sehr architektonisches ich Kön
es nicht ich arbeite nicht mit
Fluchtpunkten Perspektiven
proportional ist das alles oft einfach
verkehrt was ich da mache aber das mein
großes Glück ist dass die Figuren
Ausdruck haben die ich zeichne und dass
das halt alles zusammenpst und das kann
man glaube ich dafür brauchst du ein
Talent und dann habe ich halt geübt das
auch das erste was ich Leuten schreibe
die mir eine Mail schicken was hast du
für ein Tipp für mich wie kann ich
besser werden ich sag üb üb einfach ich
hab ich habe einfach mein Leben lang
immer gezeichnet und ich kam von der
Schule nach Hause und hab gezeichnet und
ich komme nachts nach Hause wenn ich
feiern war und Zeichn weil ich dann
inspiriert bin weil ich eine Idee habe
das ist oft am nächsten Tag totaler Mist
weil ich halt aber ist manchmal was
geniales dabei ja na klar na klar und
ich habe einfach Spaß dran das macht mir
große Freude und deswegen habe ich das
dann perfektioniert du wirst nur besser
indem du trainierst das ist auch wie
beim Sport du musst du musst den Muskel
halt einfach zeigen wie er halt sich wie
er kräftiger werden kann und das geht
nur durch Training K auf doch du liebst
schwarzen Humor bist du
depressiv ich kriege nicht selten
E-Mails von Leuten die durch eine echt
schwere Zeit im Leben gegangen sind auf
welche Art auch immer eine Krankheit
oder na gut Depression ist natürlich
auch eine Krankheit oder
die hatten keinen Beruf also haben ihren
Job verloren oder irgendwas schlimmes
jand ist gestorben und
von gerade von solchen Menschen krieg
ich Feedback die diesen Humor sehr
lieben die mögen das die sagen nicht was
machst du was Schre mir ist das und das
passiert wie kann man darüber ein Witz
das habe ich schon gehört ja mache ich
aber nicht also ich habe ich habe
überhaupt nicht den den Wunsch zu
provozieren ich habe auch nicht den
Wunsch zu verletzen aber ich schließe
einfach niemanden aus das heißt ich habe
z.B Cartoons in denen Leute im Rollstuhl
eine Rolle spielen und dann könnte man
natürlich natürlich auch ist auch schon
passiert aber eher so freundschaftlich
so von aus bekanntenkrass kann man das D
machen ich sag ja aber wieso ich ich ich
ma ja keinen Witz über Behinderte ich
mache einen Witz mit Leuten im rollstuh
mit Behinderten die schließen nicht aus
das ist eine Situation die denen
passieren könnte und dann wird die durch
diesen Spruch aufgeworen und das Fin ich
total in Ordnung wichtig und da kriege
ich auch positives Feedback drauf zu
Seen aber ein kleiner Teil gibt ja auch
Zunder ganz selten wirklich extrem
selten also das ich kann es jetzt nicht
mal in dem Prozentzahl nennen Feedback
ist gut got dank dann wünsche ich dir
dass das weiterhin so bleibt das wünsche
ich dir auch so vielen Dank danke Ralf
tschüss
tschüss super sehr schön ich hoffe es
hat dir Spaß gemacht ach es
ging der war gut